das war ein sehr interessanter und auch
belebender prozess für unsere partei und
ein sehr fairer wettkampf zwischen rhein
und jetzt kommen wir zum ergebnis meinte
am samstagvormittag gab es in einer sehr
kurzen zwei die wahl eines neuen
cdu-vorsitzenden auf fast ein jahr
gewartet worden ist auf armin laschet
entfielen 3 180 stimmen auf friedrich
merz 385 stimmen und auf norbert röttgen
am ende ist es ein schwacher sieg ein
knapper sieg
ich sage mal 21 viel geschmähten
establishments der partei warum hat er
gewonnen erst jetzt bei der die
unterstützung hatte und zweitens weil er
wahrscheinlich auch die beste rede
gehalten hat bestens funktioniert in
diesem video format wird einigermaßen
wenn man sagt natürlich also die sonst
auf einem parteitag und alle bergleute
hatten eine erkennungsmarke die sie
immer an den nagel hängte wenn sie
wieder über tage waren heil und gesund
und diese bergmanns marke trägt mein
vater der später lehrer war bis heute an
seinem schlüsselbund weil ihnen das
immer erinnert an dieses vertrauen dass
er unter tage gelernt hat und er hat
eine sehr eindeutige botschaften seiner
rede hieß wenn ihr wollt dass wir als
partei land zusammen bleiben wenn ihr
den indikator haben wollt dann bin ich
der richtige wir müssen integrieren
können eine gesellschaft zusammenhalten
sehr unterschiedliche menschen
zusammenführen das ist harte arbeit
man muss zuhören man muss unangenehmes
hören
man muss auch mit menschen zusammen
vorhanden die man vielleicht nicht zur
mahd würde ich märz hat die schwester
rede gehalten was nicht wie vor zwei
jahren oder gut zwei jahren
mit irgendwelchen scheinwerfern zu tun
hatte oder sonst was vielleicht liegt
ihm das videoformat nicht so vor allen
dingen aber war sie ohne ganz klaren
fokus derzeit ein bisschen übers
regieren gerede wir sind als deutsche
christdemokraten fest entschlossen diese
nächste deutsche bundesregierung auch
wieder zu führen
seit über das bisschen über die partei
geredet er hat ein bisschen über
frauenpolitik geredet ich höre und lese
ja teilweise nicht in unserer partei
aber außerhalb ich hätte da ein altes
bild vor augen
liebe freunde freunde wenn das so wäre
dann hätten wir meine töchter schon
längst die gelbe karte gezeigt und meine
frau mich auch vor 40 jahren nicht
geheiratet
ich weiß dass wir hier besser werden
müssen wenn man zusammen fast könnte man
nicht sagen
erst war die nachricht im märz den
delegierten mit auf den weg gegeben
hätte sicherlich hätten viele von seinen
anhängern noch mehr klare kante und
gesundheit erwartet märz ist 65 war
kosten der wirtschaft als aufsichtsrat
erfolgreich wird es auch weiter machen
können wenn er das will oder auch in der
politik etwas zu gewinnen
er hat zwar planen können befürchten
müssen dass er nicht gewählt wird nicht
vorsitzender ist aber auf der anderen
seite hat er ja in dem lager wo er doch
er noch bei klasse steht auch wenn er
selber sagt ich bin kein lager hat er
stimme mit eingesammelt also ich wenig
sagen dass er jetzt laschet einen preis
nennen kann
das kriege ich dafür aber zumindest kann
es sich gewisse hoffnungen machen dass
laschet denkt sollte ist einmal im bund
zwar eine regierung einigung kam leider
verloren hätte stünde da als ein
nordrhein-westfälischer
ministerpräsident und landesvorsitzender
dem mann gefragt hättest du kannst mal
das so weitermachen
fast nach belieben nach dem höchsten
gegriffen
hast du das nicht bekommen beschädigt
dass nicht die ich nicht auch daher mag
auch hier besonders groß gewesen
armin laschet und friedrich merz und so
hat der bundesparteitag entschieden auf
armin laschet entfallen 5 121 stimmen
und auch friedrich merz 4 166 stimmen
damit ist armin laschet gewählt auch
nicht war das märzen nach der wahl als
er noch einmal für einen kurzen moment
das mikrofon auch bekommen hat zwar
gratuliert hat aber er hat keine
ausdrückliche wahlempfehlung an seine
fans in seiner anhänger gegeben haben
ihn halt lieber neuer vorsitzender der
christlich demokratischen union
deutschlands herzlichen glückwunsch zu
deinem erfolg
herzlichen dank für das gute miteinander
dass wir in den letzten zehn monaten
hatten merz hat lediglich gratuliert und
das unterscheidet sich schon von seiner
stellungnahme vor der wahl wo er gesagt
hat alle die bären favorit nicht
gewonnen hat sollen bitte denjenigen in
der briefwahl wählen der am ende
gewonnen hat das hat er nicht
wiederholen
wir dürfen uns sehr gespannt sein wie
die wortmeldung von friedrich merz in
der nächsten zeit sein wird
viel erfolg es wird ein wichtiges jahr
das vor uns steht es wird eine enorm
anstrengende zeit die jetzt für uns alle
in den nächsten wochen und monaten zu
bestehen ist lieber armin aber auch noch
einmal lieber norbert herzlichen dank
für das gute miteinander und die lieber
armin viel erfolg bei dem was du jetzt
forst